a woman has gone viral because she has a
PHD and she took an IQ test next to some
guy that she thought was just a dumb
rube hillbilly and the dumb rub
hillbilly did better on the IQ test than
she did I'm 21 I'm a high school
graduate and I work in the Marine Corps
I'm 30 years old I have my PhD in cancer
biology and I work in a Biotech Industry
grad school I went to University of
South Carolina and undergrad I went to
University of Florida so number one is
Raymond number two would be
Kaye number three will be Tyler and
number four would be sha number five is
Shawn and number six is
[Music]
Maria I am not surprised by this one of
the biggest
downsides to University expansion and to
credentialism is that it convinces
people that they're much smarter than
they are